the jurogan experience so you start off
with this first mile
and then you eventually work your way up
to all these challenges yes
yes and then eventually you decide
i am gonna row across the atlantic
ocean by myself yeah so
okay so the row um i was on a bus
right and i was like talking to someone
sitting next to me
and we were talking about endurance
challenges
and um i was a
stubborn know-it-all 19 year old so of
course i was like
oh i've heard it all i know people climb
mount everest i know people sail around
the world i know about all these things
and
then he mentioned his friend rode across
the atlantic and
that was like that just stopped me in my
tracks like
what like people can do that like i
never
it was so far beyond anything i ever
imagined
and um i think like
with endurance what's so cool about
endurance
is like at a certain point everyone's
body hurts
right so what makes endurance
like a really cool experience is seeing
how the human will
and how like determination and how a
strong mind
like you it's a requirement because
everyone no matter how fast or slow you
are
is going through that that mental wall
and so um yeah i found out about ocean
rowing and i was really
captivated not only by that mental
component
because like if you do a marathon you go
home you take your shower
you um you have people cheering you on
but
but ocean rolling you're stripped raw of
that and and something about that
was intriguing to me because it's like
okay how can you dig
deep internally when you don't have
the you know the finish line um
you know whatever party and like the
swag and the people and the nice cozy
bed
and i just kind of i liked that idea of
like
being so stripped raw that you have to
dig deeper than you ever
would if you didn't have all those other
externals
so yeah i found out about it on a bus i
went home
and went and googled everything i could
about ocean rowing and it was
at a time where i did my first ultra
marathon so it was like a hundred
kilometer run
or 62 miles and it was again one of
those moments where i was like
i never thought i could do that and my
body proved otherwise so what are all
the other things that i'm saying
i can't do but maybe i can so
it was really that information
at that particular time where i was like
really open to the idea of wow maybe it
is possible
but um it was a matter of like
researching everything it wasn't like oh
i gotta do this it was oh i gotta find
out everything because
i mean if someone told geo someone rode
across the atlantic wouldn't the first
thing be like is that really true
like so i mean that was the first place
i i looked like are people legitimately
doing that
how much time was it between you finding
out about it and you actually doing it
two years that's not that long no
did what kind of training did you do um
so like physical training
like compared to doing like
i've trained for like iron man's and
then trained for adventures like
physical purely physical to like these
more adventure type things
and like training for an iron man 90
is like what you're doing in the gym for
ocean rowing
and for like the more adventure type
um athletic pursuits i would say that
like
90 was like the logistics like you could
be the most fit person in the world but
if you don't have a boat
what does it matter like so i spent most
of my time
just like sorting out through all the
logistics the sponsorship getting the
gear
training with the gear but um yeah
like my training priorities for rowing
and ocean
were um injury prevention so i did a lot
with like strengthening my core and my
lower back
and then on the weekends is when i would
do like a six to eight hour row
training row just to get more to get
used to the boat and the equipment more
than anything else
and you would go on a lake lake erie
yeah
yeah now how fast do you go
on this boat uh like
maybe i would go like 30 miles a day no
no
how fast like perhaps three two or three
miles two or three miles per hour
so basically like the speed of walking
yeah so
um my boat was a 19 foot
row boat it was like 400 pounds but once
it was fully loaded
it was a thousand pounds so it did have
like a sliding seat
yes okay so um
i i had a sliding seat so that meant
that like my
legs and my back were the main source of
like
power but um i think the best
like you mean a sliding sleeve like a
rowing machine exactly
so like so that helps you it means that
like the power was coming from the most
powerful parts of my body not
my arms so some people assume like oh
it's just your upper body it's just your
arms but
in fact it's more your legs and back but
uh so this thing's going two or three
miles an hour correct and how many miles
is the atlantic ocean how many miles
three thousand
yeah three thousand so oh my god
don't think about it just don't even
think about it oh my god that's so far
that's so far it was the worst reaching
the halfway point just because like
how long did it take you the whole trip
70 days 70 days
that's not that bad when you think about
it how far you went
yeah i would say so yeah i i anticipated
it would be 70 or 100 days
oh yeah that's a big gap i had 30 days
of
extra food and oh that's good yeah
yeah was anybody monitoring you uh i had
like a tracker
so people could like look online and see
where i was
um but there wasn't like a follow boat
or anything like that
what are those nights like it was pretty
amazing yeah
so of course the stars were amazing like
shooting stars and just like yeah
breathtaking and then what surprised me
like i thought it was like wait
is this real am i hallucinating but the
the i think the most stunning part was
actually looking in the water because
they had
like um this type of glowing plankton so
it was like a
phosphorescence so sometimes i would see
things glowing in a distance and then
all around my boat anytime my oar
hit the water like i would see all of
that
and wow yeah like i was so busy
planning the trip and the logistics that
i didn't know
like what wildlife i'd see and so that
was definitely like a pleasant surprise
to
to see that must have been really crazy
yeah have you ever seen
no no i've seen it on video so you can
find a video of it
um what is it called it's
bioluminescence but there
are like puerto rico is probably the
closest place to here that has really
good
bioluminescence too like
yeah so that it really looked like that
yeah
yes that's amazing very trippy
that is so wild yeah so i could put my
hand
in the water and um did you take any
photos or film it
i did have some uh film and uh
yes sometimes i no
like you can't really take good i mean
yeah i didn't have really good
bioluminescence photos
look at that shore that's insane
now you said the stars stars were
amazing yes
like how amazing i mean light pollution
at all
right yeah i mean i i mean it in some
ways it felt like i was just like
living this national geographic
experience of like
you know i had dolphins come right up to
my boat i had
um yeah yeah like uh i think it was like
the fourth way mark
i was like i want to celebrate and um
my way of celebrating was very limited
it was like oh am i gonna have two
snickers bars like
there's not really anything other than
what i had but
this pot of dolphins surrounded my boat
and we're doing like flips and tricks
and like
really right at that moment that i was
reaching it so
yeah the the dolphins and
sharks and birds and
um i even had like fish following right
underneath
my boat like because barnacles would
grow
it was like i on on the side of my boat
i would
um scrub them off but sometimes they
would just keep following
my boat so every time i i named them ed
ed and eddie but i had like three
dorados that would
keep following and birds that came on my
boat
wow yeah catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience